c'est un sujet très cool je pense que ça
vous aura pas échappé d'ailleurs je sais
pas si ça vous a échappé au nord vient
de présenter son premier smartphone
pliable et c'est un point qui est
vraiment intéressant pourquoi parce que
au nord si on revient un peu dans le
passé quand on regarde l'historique de
la marque et bien c'est une marque qui
est destiné pour les jeunes jeune public
il n'y a pas longtemps huawei honor
travailler ensemble fait partie du même
groupe aujourd'hui c'est plus tard sont
vraiment séparés et au nord a pris son
indépendance
mais au nord était la marque jeune de
huawei la marque qui était pour un
public fasciné plus jeunes nous avons
autour de 400 500 euros 600 euros pour
des produits c'est un peu l'idée voir un
petit peu moins là aujourd'hui ils sont
complètement indépendants donc
l'histoire de voir où est terminée on
tourne la page on l'a vu justement il
n'ya pas longtemps avec leonor 5 ans qui
a récupéré les services google donc
c'est intéressant et là ils reviennent
avec un nouveau smartphone c'est le
honor magic v alors ces honneurs magic v
année je voulais me sur mon écran là je
trouve intéressant pourquoi parce que ça
monte plein de choses s'annoncent déjà
la volonté de au nord de montrer les
muscles d'innovation d'aller plus haut
de se positionner à un autre tarif avec
un produit qui est extrêmement
différente très innovant avec son
premier smartphone pliable et ça c'est
vraiment mais vraiment très intéressant
ça paraît compliqué pour une marque qui
dit nous on va proposer les produits un
certain prix pas trop cher d'arrivée
qu'un smartphone qui va coûter un jeu
tout de suite le tarif gelé engone
9999 one ça fait à peu près mille 400
euros hors taxes à quelque chose près ce
soit à peu près 1680 euros ttc même si
on imagine que le tarif était positionné
un peu plus bas vous recoller à la
concurrence en france malgré tout on est
à plus de 1500 euros sur ce smartphone
alors je dis pas que ça ne vaut pas
attention il ya l'innovation c'est
intéressante c'est un joli produit oms
le détail dans quelques instants mais au
nord reste une marque propose des
smartphones de bonne facture de bonne
qualité mais pas trop cher là on est à
1506 autre chose mais c'est un pliable
je suis d'accord donc est-ce que ils
vont réussir à venir conquérir de
nouveaux clients à 1500 euros je sais
pas mais on verra et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un
smartphone pliable ya plein
d'innovations on va pas le proposer à
700 euros julien moment ça marcherait
pas tout ce qui lie à l'intérieur est
vraiment bien fait bonne facture il ya
des composants très haut de gamme
notamment au niveau du processeur on est
sur le dernier processeur de qualcomm
snapdragon 8 de première génération
gênes 1 ou alors c'est maicon et john
wayne comme on veut ça me paraît logique
on se retrouve avec un prix très élevé à
plus de 1500 euros pour autant ça reste
sonné c'est ça qui est intéressant alors
je dis pas que le produit n'est pas bien
parce que je dis pas que c'est parce que
c'est au nord le produit n'est pas mais
c'est pas vrai on en fabrique de très
jolis produits mais c'est pas leur
positionnement donc le positionnement
change donc c'est intéressant mais on
l'a vu il l'année dernière avec un chien
au mic a étiré sa gamme il ya non il ya
deux ans puis ce match et au mic a étiré
sa gamme vers le haut en allant sur du
très haut de gamme là c'est le cas alors
est-ce que honor va jouer aussi un
virage à 180 degrés pour arriver avec de
l'ultra haut de gamme avec du très haut
de gamme j'en sais rien en tout cas ce
que ça monte ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est que le marché du
pillage ou du client quand on vous jure
et pliable en tout cas se démocratise de
plus en plus on l'a vu souvenez vous en
mai il ya quelques jours avec moi au cs
on a été voir sur le stand de tcl il y
avait le tcl chicago un smartphone qui
se plie comme le samsung galaxy ses deux
filles 3 qui se plie pour devenir qui
est grand et qui devient plus petit sauf
que ils ont dit eux notre smartphone et
coûterait plus mille euros c'est pas ce
qu'on veut pour tester l on veut
proposer un smartphone dans et autour de
7 cents et quelques euros ampli yable
donc ça c'est un proto il ne verra
jamais le jour on vous présentera plus
tard probablement en hausse maarten qui
se plie mais moins cher là c'est pas du
tout le discours de honor là le discours
c'est de dire ok voilà notre premier
smartphone pliable il est réservé pour
l'instant uniquement au marché chinois
alors est ce que c'est une question de
l'application qui n'est pas complètement
développée et optimisée pour le marché
européen
le marché global en tout cas c'est ce
que nous a montrée au pot il n'ya pas
longtemps souvenez vous je vous ai
montré le premier smartphone pliable duo
pop a un nom roulable un pliable j'ai
adoré ce format super intéressant mais
nous on dit bon ba aujourd'hui d'un
point de vue applicatifs s'est pas
complètement optimisé donc on va rester
un peu tranquille et on le sortira
probablement en france mais plus tard le
temps que les développeurs proposent de
nouvelles applications on verra est ce
que c'est aujourd'hui pour cette raison
que honor n'arrive pas tout de suite en
français ce qu'ils viennent un petit peu
testé sur le marché chinois voir si ça
va arriver au pas peut-être est-ce que
aussi le marché chinois et plus mature
pour avoir des smartphones pliable est
ce qu'ils ont de plus grosses appétence
oblige à bhl j'en sais rien en tout cas
pour l'instant ça n'arrive pas en france
c'est une certitude mais ce qu'on voit
c'est que c'est exactement le même form
factor que le samsung galaxy z folle de
3 c'est-à-dire un smartphone que vous
prenez que vous ouvrez pour obtenir un
plus grand écran une plus grande surface
sauf qu'ici et bien l'écran est un peu
plus grand que ce qu'on avance sur les
épaules de 3 pourquoi alors regardez on
va venir on va aller voir un petit peu
car dès l'âge ou monde sur le site
directement de honor l'écran lorsqu'il
est ouvert aux plats regard d'eva
lorsqu'il est ouvert comme ça attendez
on a des vidéos va se passer voilà ici
lorsqu'il est ouvert c'est du 7,9 pouces
mais sur le z folle de 3 cdu 7,6 pouces
ok on est sûr de l'oled alors chez
samsung on est sur du caïdat mika
molette 2,6 alors le truc un peu bizarre
et cissé qui nous ont mis un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 m attendais ce
qu'ils ont fait ici ici 80 dire ça c'est
très surprenant c'est très bizarre parce
que chez samsung vous êtes sûre du sang
versé alors on pourrait se dire ok mais
du 90 à cela mais lorsqu'il est plié il
passe sur du 120 hertz et là c'est
bizarre c'est extrêmement bizarre aux
trois cantons de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz fermé alors que le plus
intéressant c'est l'écran à l'intérieur
sauf que là propres de samsung est plus
logique d'avoir du sang maher partout
alors est ce que c'est une question de
coût est la technologie la maîtrise pas
complètement je sais pas en tout cas ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on voit
qu'à priori l'écran a priori je n'ai pas
pris en main c'est vraiment de la
découverte a l'air plutôt bien fait on
est sur un milliard de couleurs des
comptes qui certifie hdr 10 plus une
gamme de couleurs dci p3 hockey why not
ça m'ira très bien la résolution a/c du
2272 par
1984 pixels ok contenu full hd plus et
quand il est repliée et bien vous êtes
ici sur un ratio 21 points 3/9 tennis
couverts et bien c'est un ratio
quasiment car est presque 1 c'est du dix
neuvième et quand il est fermé c'est
exactement l'oled un milliard de coût
agir nice + également un écran de 6 45
pouces alors que sur le samsung galaxy z
folle de trois ans les sur du 6,2 pouces
d'eau qui sont un peu plus grand ces
écrans que ce que nous propose sa
mission je dis bien un peu plus grand
apportera un peu plus de confort de
visionnage bon ça change pas grand chose
ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est la
charnière alors cadets reçoivent cette
charnière est ce qu'il demandera la une
nous montre là alors c'est la partie du
bas qui aurait été intéressante alors je
les ai vus sur un test là j'ai regardé
sur leur site on se dit non c'est pas
très clair on voit pas très bien mais
j'ai trouvé un test par un créateur
asiatique est ce qu'ils étaient super
intéressant et ce qu'il montre est ce qu
effectivement à dire il n'y a pas de
petits jours en bas donc il est
complètement plaque est complètement
fermée donc le système de charnière a
l'air d'être vraiment pas mal on voit
quand même la plus dure je sais pas si
on l'a senti race ou le doigt comme ce
qu'on peut sentir ce samsung galaxy
cette folle de 3 euros se testera
peut-être plus tard dont je vous invite
à vous abonner s'est pas déjà fait
qu'est ce petit bouton rouge là comme ça
vous saurez tout et nous allons jusqu'à
200 milles plie au niveau de cette
charnière bon un grand classique comme
ce que propose des autres côté logiciel
c'est magic wheel 6.0 basé sur un
android 12 la performance bien gardé je
voulais dire c'est du snapdragon 8 james
wan jen un jean one jean 1 va dire ça sa
vraie bonne nuit jonone c'est bien comme
ça j'ai gravées en 40 nanomètres vous
avez 12 giga de ram et vous avez soit
256 72 juin de stockage ou donc à ce
qu'il faut sous le capot et à savoir
qu'ici en plus vous avez une grosse
batterie de 4750 mais il y aurait en
fait ces deux petites batteries fin de
grande batterie de batteries pour un
total de 4000 750 millions terreur et de
la recharge rapide 66 web qui vous leur
charge de 0 à 50 % en seulement 15
minutes bon ok et alors il vous le
montre aussi point de vue photo c'est
intéressant parce que vous avez trois
capteurs plus un regard des jours montre
vous avez donc un grand bouquet votre
premier c'est votre grand temps que 50
méga pixels sans équivalent en 23 mm
ouvre à f 1.9 assez logique ça me paraît
logique par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est que samsung c'est du
12 mégapixels ici c'est du cinquante bon
une fois de plus il faut pas trop se
fier aux chiffres il faut vraiment voir
les résultats sur le terrain pour
l'instant je lé pa j'espère l'avoir j'en
ai fait la demande en tout cas donc on
verra si on peut l'avoir un moment ou un
autre on va avoir ensuite regarder un
ultra grand angle pareil 50 méga pixels
on peut venir faire de la macro ici en
hd on est sur un équivalent 13 mm
ouverture de f/2 points devant vous le
voyez c'est du sang 22 degrés bon ça me
paraît assez logique aussi s'il n'y a
pas de stabilisation optique 1 ni l'art
ni sur l'autre côté donc vous allez voir
qu'on veut faire de la vidéo sont quatre
cas c'est lui avec une stabilisation
électronique mais pas de stabilisation
optique vous avez en plus une petite
caméra tough qui est planqué sur le côté
et il ya un autre capteur attendait ce
que je les louper c'est une possible
débat c'est assez le spectra n ends
caméra c'est 1,50 mégapixels soit
l'équivalent d'un millimètre touvre f
2.0 en fait lui va venir faire quoi il a
bien travaillé de concert soit et votre
grand temps que votre une très bonne
entente pour vous optimisez l'image
meilleur contraste mais en luminosité
meilleures couleurs bref il est là en
plus pour rendre l'image beaucoup plus
belle c'est un smartphone qui malgré
tout reste lourd 288 g alors on était
sur 271 grammes sans galaxy z folle de
trois ça reste louvre ses smartphones
pliable info vraiment imaginer vous êtes
quand même comme si vous avez deux
smartphones on a quelque chose près donc
fatalement le poids va être là mais ça
me paraît une fois de plus logique vu ce
grand format ici vous avez de la double
nanosims du bluetooth 5.2 par contre si
vous n'avez aucune certification de
résistance à l'eau et à la poussière
tandis que si on prend le smartphone de
samsung à tarif équivalent on est sûr de
l'ip et x8 donc résistant à l'eau et à
la poussière et de la même manière et
c'est intéressant on vous le montre vous
avez pour faire mon lacet toutes les
photos de la productivité bien
évidemment avec rôles sont ok je vous le
passez on peut faire du multi écran peut
faire plein plein plein de choses mais à
la différence du smartphone de samsung
ou vous avez et c'est la très grande
force de saxo et si vous avez un espen
donc ça vous permet grâce aux
smartphones de samsung d'avoir la
productivité je pensais que cette folle
de trois ils ont enterré la gamme note
déjà ils n'ont pas sorti de l'année
dernière donc c'est samsung n'y aura pas
de gamme note à mon avis bien à mon avis
ici on peut pas venir l'utiliser avec un
stylet donc d'un côté chez samsung vous
allez avoir un style et ça va être
vraiment intéressant pour la prise de
notes le dessin griffonné dans la mesure
où vous utilisez aussi je sais pas si
vous utilisez un style et moi je ne suis
pas utilisateurs de stylet mais je peux
comprendre que des personnes qui veulent
le faire et que ça intéresse donc c'est
vrai que c'est un poids fort du côté de
chez samsung que vous allez pas à
retrouver ici bon d'un autre côté faut
bien qu'ils des maraudes point qui est
intéressant du côté de samsung est bien
c'est que lorsque vous ouvrirez votre
smartphone bien vous avez une caméra qui
est planqué sous l'écran alors c'est
intéressant oui et non parce que c'est
une caméra 4 mégapixels donc en termes
de celle fille à l'intérieur c'est pas
ouf ici par contre sur le honor magic v
vous avez une caméra de 40 2 mégapixels
à l'intérieur mais également à
l'extérieur lorsqu'il est fermé vous
avez deux caméras de celle fille tandis
que chez samsung je dise une 4
mégapixels à l'intérieur sous l'écran
planqué donc c'est pas mal pour
l'immersion mais à l'extérieur c'est une
10 mégapixels une fois de plus il
faudrait vraiment vu au revoir en
testant en comparant pouvoir vraiment se
rendre compte sans papiers maca des
choses qui vont dans le sens du nord
magic vi entoure 1500 euros pour venir
les positionner en face à face et il ya
des choses qui vont aussi dans le sens
du smartphone de samsung le galaxy z
paul ii iii le fait d'abord un style et
une caméra sous l'écran le fait d'avoir
dû dynamique amoled 2 x aussi sous
l'écran le fait d'avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement de sang versé intérieur
pour le gaming ça sera vachement bien
tandis que de l'autre côté bien on a un
peu plus de mégapixels or à voir si
c'est vraiment intéressant si la qualité
est supérieure le fait d'avoir un
smartphone qui semble complètement je
sais pas il faut vraiment les tester
pour se rencontrer en tout cas ça monte
vraiment tout est super intéressant
c'est que peut-être que honor va venir
prendre un virage pour proposer une
gamme plus large alors qu'il ne le
faisait pas avant avant on était sûrs du
milieu de gamme ont flirté avec le
premium mais aussi dans le milieu de
gamme ici c'est très clairement un
smartphone premium c'est très clairement
un smartphone qui montre les muscles
vous avez beaucoup de performances
j'avais une grosse batterie vous avez
plein de belles innovations il a l'air
pas parfait bien évidemment mais par
contre il a l'air vachement bien et s'il
continue dans cette lignée là c'est à
dire étendre leur gamme vers le haut de
gamme est bien de voir et vivre des
trucs vraiment cool et honor va plus
être qu'une seule marque dédiée aux
jeunes va être une mare beaucoup plus là
pour tout un chacun en tout cas c'est ce
que ça semble vouloir décider c'est pas
si vous êtes d'accord avec moi je sais
pas s'ils ont partagé le même avis que
moi en tout cas je serais vraiment
intéressant et on se reverra ça de près
parce qu'à mon avis en 2022 ils ont
drones maps ils vont nous montrer plein
smartphones et j'imagine que la gamme va
s'élargir énormément qu'on s'arrêtera
pas aux honneurs 50 mais qu'on ira bien
au dessus aussi envahira ça je vous
invite à venir vous abonner dès
maintenant surtout dites moi ce que vous
en pensez si on devait comparer le honor
magic v versus le samsung galaxy z folle
de 3 vers lequel est ce que vous iriez
alors si c'est en terme de non j'irai
d'un smartphone de honor le nom est
beaucoup plus court et c'est quand même
vachement mieux au nord magic v sanaa
tandis que samsung galaxy z folle de
troyes où ces rallonges mais c'est cool
parce que vous en pensez en commentaire
par lequel vous iriez qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette idée de la marque de
honor qui va élargir sa gamme est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi ou pas il on
se retrouve très vite pour continuer par
l'etec l'embrassa bientôt de charles
bisous
[Musique]
où